In the networking code, you may have
noticed that there are different types
of exceptions, but
you didn't know what they're for.
Now we haven't formally talked
about them, so let's do that now.
The first time you saw and exception was
in the first course in the nano degree
when we were building
the Just Java coffee ordering app.
Now the app ran into an exception and
crashed.
To debug the program,
we opened up the Android logs
to reveal the stack trace and
then discovered an IllegalStateException
was thrown when the submitOrder method
could not be found in the main activity.
Let's look at some
documentation about exceptions.
When the Java method fails, or
runs into an unexpected state,
it can throw an exception,
short for an exceptional event.
Exceptions are basically errors,
but they're also captured or
wrapped in actual instances of the
exception class, which holds information
about what went wrong and what was
happening in the system at the time.
If you look here on the left for
example, you'll also notice that there
are more specific types of exceptions
that actually extend from
the Exceptions super class.
A great example of inheritance
in use in the Java framework.
In other words,
all of these specific classes are
subclasses of the base class Exception.
For example,
here we have an IllegalStateException or
a NullPointerException.
We also saw the SecurityException
earlier in this lesson,
when the Internet permission was
missing from our Soonami App.
Now you could create a new exception
class for your own purposes.
For example, we can create
an InvalidEarthquakeException and
define it as we normally would.
Create a custom class and
then have that custom class just
extend from the base Exception class.
>From there, we can customize
the Exception to hold say,
very specify information about
an invalid earthquake scenario.
So as a developer you can write
a method that declares that it will
throw an exception.
Meaning that the code inside that
method either one, generates and
exception to indicate
a unique condition, or two,
and more commonly,
calls a method that throws an exception.
Meaning that the Android runtime tried
to execute some code, but ran into
a problem and therefore gave notice of
the problem by throwing the exception.
It's also important to note that if
an exception is thrown, it also means
that the code following the line that
caused the exception won't get executed.
So how do you do this in Java code?
There are two distinctions that
I'd like you to pay attention to.
Number one, anywhere in your Java
code where you want to cause or
invoke an exception,
you use the key word throw.
Like in this example here,
where we want to throw an
InvalidPurchase Exception(); because we
detected that something went wrong
within our completePurchase() method.
Number two, and
this is much more subtle.
Anytime our code throws an exception
that isn't a descendant of the error or
runtime Exception classes, we must
explicitly declare in our method's
signature that our method
could throw such an exception.
In Java programming speak,
this is known as a checked exception and
has the implication that any code
that calls or uses our method
must handle the exception i.e.,
call our method in a try block.
This is enforced by the Java compiler,
in other words whoever calls
the completePurchase method has to have
a backup plan if the InvalidPurchase
Exception is thrown or occurs.
We'll talk about how to handle
exceptions in the next video.
In case you'd like to learn more about
unchecked versus checked Eeceptions
in more detail, see the tutorial
linked in the notes below this video.
One more important note.
Just because there's
a standard framework for
how to use Exceptions in Java,
it doesn't mean that you should throw
exceptions every time
something goes wrong.
This is where developer
discretion comes into play.
Ideally, if we discover a problem or
a unique situation, we should try and
handle it gracefully in code.
By just falling back to some reasonable
default behavior for example, and
continuing executing if possible.
We call this failing silently.
However, should we deem that it be more
detrimental to keep going with an error
state, then we may decide it's best to
notify our calling code of the error
by throwing exception.
We've seen this in play already.
In the case of our Soonami App, when we
tried to request earthquake data from
the internet, the Android framework
code threw a SecurityException.
This is a case when it's better
to throw an exception and
crash the app as opposed to continuing
without the Internet permission.
Now if the Android framework
code had failed silently,
then we as developers would
probably be super confused
as to why we did receive
response from the server.
In the case of the Soonami and
Quick Report Apps, we won't actually be
creating our own custom exceptions or
throwing exceptions intentionally.
We will however be calling the Android
framework code that does throw exception
and we'll need to handle those
exceptions appropriately.
Let's talk about that next.